- It's micro-cheating.
It's not like cheating, cheating.
(cheerful music)
- So micro-cheating occurs when someone
goes a little bit outside the lines
of what is allowed in a relationship,
and there is some deception.
They're closing the computer
when someone walks in,
they're not sharing
everything with their partners
that they're sharing with someone else,
couples have all kinds of arrangements.
What's normal in a relationship
is what's normal to the couple.
Some people would say you
can't even have dinner
with someone you're attracted to,
but others would say
that it's totally fine
to have innocent flirtation,
so those boundaries really need
to be set within the couple.
- Pinky swear that we
will get through this,
all right?
- Deal.
- Okay.
- Kiss, seal it up.
- (laughs)
I think you can be a
little jealous at times.
- I call it like I see it.
- You're just really nice and friendly,
so I think sometimes people, like,
take it the wrong way.
- I can see that.
- We have these cards.
One side is cheating,
and the other side means it's all good.
- [Offscreen] Is it okay to
follow an ex on social media?
- I think it sometimes comes off petty
if you are, like, unfollowing people
right after you break up.
Hopefully, you're not, like,
checking in on things on a daily basis.
- (unsure humming)
- No.
I think it's okay because sometimes
your ex just needs to see
that you're doing way better than them.
- I feel like it's harmless,
unless you had some crazy
relationship or break up.
I follow my ex.
- [Offscreen] Liking an ex's picture.
- Depends how, like,
good they look, or bad.
- That shouldn't matter.
It's either, a pity like-
- It's a bad picture,
let's all like it so it
gets to the top of the feed.
- (laughs)
- Sometimes, you might just be scrolling
and then your phone
fumbles, and it's like,
"Ohhh, I left a heart on the picture."
And then it's like-
- Oh really?
- And then I would immediately
go back and untap then
so it's clear then.
That was enough.
- [Offscreen] Communicating
with an ex's family.
- Who does that?
- I don't know, not me.
- I don't even talk to
my own family that much,
so, it's like-
- True.
- Why?
- I do this. (laughs)
- I got a firm not cheating on this one.
Your mom still talks to your exes, so.
- Because I don't think it's cheating,
but I think it's a
little bit inappropriate.
- I feel like, if God forbid,
if anything happened to us,
I'd still want to know your family,
just because I really like them.
- [Offscreen] Having a
false name in your contacts.
- Why would you change a name
if there wasn't something wrong?
- You just spare people's
feelings a little bit,
so even if you're not into the person,
like, you might just change their name
just to avoid an argument.
Some girls will, like, read
into something too much,
and be like, "Oh, who's Janet?" you know?
And it'll be completely nothing,
but you don't even want to go there.
I've never done it to you, but- (laughs)
- If you are changing someone's
information, to, like,
the pizza store, or something like that,
that's admitting to you being
guilty of doing shady things.
- Yes.
That's your side piece.
- [Offscreen] Having a
work wife or work husband.
- Hmm.
- You're emotionally cheating.
There should be no work husband.
There should be no other
husband than this husband.
- I don't think he likes
this because we met at work,
so this, probably, is like-
- This is close to home.
- Okay, if you're, like,
putting wife or husband
on the end of anyone
that's not your person,
then that's sus.
- [Offscreen] Using heart or kiss emojis.
- No hearts over here.
- What?
- No love.
- What if it's like a guy
you've been friends with for a long time?
- I don't care.
- And, like, if someone DM's you,
all you can do, instead of a like button,
it's a heart button.
- The real question here is
why you getting DM's in the first place?
Just stay away from the kisses
and the hearts and all that.
- No, no liking people's
pictures and stuff with hearts,
or like, "You looking good,"
or something like that.
- Sometimes people just,
you don't need to know they're
looking good, some days.
I can see that, but if you're like-
- You've done that before.
- Yeah, we have
pretty similar answers.
- Yeah.
- I was kind of surprised.
I thought you were gonna think, like,
nothing was micro-cheating.
- We're clear on not, like,
our boundaries, and what,
like, makes us upset,
and, you know, what
affects the other person.
- We were friends before we
even got into a relationship.
We talk, like, wow, it's
a thing couples should do.
- Micro-cheating is definitely a thing.
Definitely something
that could be detrimental
to a relationship.
- I feel like you get me.
I get you.
That's why it works.